[Musique]
un peu plus de 3 mois après la décevante
performance de son parti aux élections
le chef par intérim des libéraux
québécois dit avoir tourné la page Marc
Tanguay souhaite maintenant se consacrer
à son rôle de chef de l'opposition
officielle et puis je concentrer sur le
coup de la vie l'avenir énergétique du
Québec et l'état du système de santé des
priorités qu'il a d'ailleurs énoncé à
François Legault lors de son tête-à-tête
avec lui la semaine dernière je rejoins
Marc Tanguay dans nos studios à Montréal
merci d'être avec nous bonjour monsieur
Thibault parlons de la rencontre que
vous avez eu avec monsieur Legault et
tous vos collègues des autres partis
également est-ce que d'après vous ça
veut dire un changement de torse au
Québec on va juger l'arbre assez fruits
j'ai eu l'occasion de saluer cette
initiative là du premier ministre logo
je pense que c'est une bonne chose que
le premier ministre du Québec même si il
a reçu évidemment un mandat avec 90
députés il a les quatre premières 4
prochaines années de lui je pense que
c'est important qu'il écoute et qu'il
écoute davantage bien évidemment dans
son corps et pas dans la bonne direction
on a eu une discussion tout à fait je
dirais agréable frange on a eu
l'occasion d'avancer certaines
propositions il a pris beaucoup de notes
maintenant on va voir quels seront les
solutions qu'il décidera de mettre de
l'avant vous avez proposé entre autres
la création d'une commission nationale
sur l'énergie moi ça a été reçu je pense
que le Premier ministre le goût est tout
à fait conscient de la complexité de du
débat quant à l'avenir énergétique du
Québec pour nous la partie libéral du
Québec
l'avenir énergétique est intimement lié
à l'avenir économique les deux vont de
pair alors nous devons avoir ce que
François Legault lui-même a mentionné
lors du discours inaugural à l'automne
dernier lorsqu'il parlait d'une d'un
débat national lorsque sophie Brochu
d'Hydro-Québec disait en mars 2022 ça
nous prend une jasette nationale mais
nous ce qu'on propose évidemment c'est
d'avoir cette conversation là mais en
même temps on a l'impression que l'idée
de monsieur Legault elle est bien
arrêtée il veut plus de barrage ça donne
quoi la conversation
la conversation c'est justement c'est de
prendre des bonnes décisions vous ne
pouvez pas aujourd'hui dire vous voulez
plus de barrages fin de la discussion le
dossier est complexe ce fibrochu avait
déposé en 2022 un plan stratégique
jusqu'en 2026 on se rend compte que même
là ce plan doit être mise à jour il y
avait des chapitres entiers qui
demeuraient à écrire et sophie Brochu a
invitait la collectivité invité entre
autres le gouvernement à nous lancer
dans cette conversation dans cette
discussion nationale le pourquoi pour
savoir comment devons-nous investir dans
l'éolien dans le solaire
l'hydroélectricité les énergies
renouvelables pour que notre économie
continue et devienne de plus en plus
fortes nous devons électrifier nos
processus et en sens là ça prend une
vision vous pouvez pas gérer ça à la
petite semaine j'aimerais qu'on parle de
santé parce que ça aussi est abordé lors
de votre rencontre avec monsieur Legault
il y a beaucoup beaucoup de pression
dans les hôpitaux dans les urgences au
Québec on fait quoi à court terme pour
soulager ça d'après vous mais je pense
qu'il faut revenir écrire à des horaires
de travail qui sont descend il y a une
démobilisation
au fil des ans puis ça fonctionne pas ou
en tout cas c'est difficile à emprunter
c'est pas le cas actuellement le
gouvernement n'a pas été dans ce le TSO
toujours court au Québec tant
supplémentaire obligatoire vous êtes une
mère monoparentale vous devez aller
chercher votre enfant à la fin de sa
journée scolaire ou de service de garde
vous vous faites dire ben vous pourrez
pas quitter à 4h comme c'était prévu on
vous rajoute un 8h c'est obligatoire
c'est démobilisant est-ce que l'on voit
là il y a une hémorragie les infirmières
nos professionnels quittent le système
de la santé certains s'en vont au privé
nous devons donc avoir des conditions de
travail humaines ça ça passe par le
temps supplémentaire obligatoire qui
doit être aboli et également des ratios
qui soient humains l'organisation du
travail aussi et de l'amélioration à
faire quand tu as l'organisation du
travail le ministre du B dit qu'il y a
un problème de culture à la santé mais
rappelons lui qu'il est dans sa
cinquième année pendant ce temps-là moi
je vois québécoise québécois qui disent
dans le temps des fêtes là on se disait
c'est pas le temps de tomber malade ça
me tente pas d'aller à l'urgence je veux
pas aller à l'urgence c'est pas normal
alors nous devons agir des solutions il
y en a ils doivent les appliquer bon
énergie santé vous avez aussi parlé avec
Monsieur Lugo le goût d'inflation de
l'angle de garderie sur quoi il a été le
plus allumé ou le plus intéressant où
est-ce qu'il y a pris le plus de notes
vous dire pris beaucoup de notes tout à
l'heure sur quoi il a caché d'après vous
particulièrement je dois lui dire là je
dois lui dire qu'il a pris beaucoup de
notes sur surtout les sujets notamment
en matière de service de garde vous le
savez là c'est c'est reconnu la liste
d'attente de 52000 enfants qui n'ont
toujours pas de place en service de
garde je pense que le premier ministre
est tout à fait conscient que non
seulement ça nous empêche d'agir tôt
auprès de nos jeunes qui ont pas de
place auprès d'éducatrice des
professionnels de la petite enfance donc
agir tout mais également point de vue
économique le fait qu'il y ait autant de
parents souvent ce sont les mers qui
demeurent à la maison mettre leurs
carrière en veilleuse donc un coup
économique dans un deuxième lieu alors
je pense que là-dessus il est
parfaitement conscient du problème mais
encore une fois Monsieur Thibault ils
sont dans leur cinquième année et nous
n'avons toujours pas vu autre chose il
nous demande de le juger sur ses
résultats la situation a empiré au cours
des cinq dernières années alors au lieu
de prendre de très bonnes notes j'espère
qu'il arrivera avec des solutions
étrangères et développer les places
notamment en CPA moi qu'on parle de du
Parti libéral par qu'on parle de vous
faites trois mois un peu plus de trois
mois maintenant qu'on qu'on a tourné la
page sur l'élection provinciale ou la
performance en disant présentation a été
décevante pour vous est-ce que on a
vraiment tourné la page est-ce qu'on est
passé on est rendu ailleurs chez vous je
pense qu'il faut en revenir là je vais
dire on a tous été conscient que ça a
été une défaite historique du Parti
libéral du Québec maintenant on est face
à un gouvernement 90 députés kakis
François Legault qui a beaucoup beaucoup
de pouvoir comment maintenant va-t-il
atteindre ses résultats nous ce qu'on
souhaite le comme opposition officielle
libérale c'est que le gouvernement
puisse parce qu'on est là pour
travailler dans l'intérêt des
Québécoises et québécois et quand encore
une fois François Legault nous dit vous
nous jugerez sur les résultats
malheureusement force cette constater
qu'en éducation en justice en service de
garde en santé les résultats sont
négatifs sont pas bons alors on va faire
notre ouvrage notre travail de
positionne on va suggérer mais on va
talonner le gouvernement pour avoir de
bons résultats comment vous l'envisagez
votre travail de de chef de l'opposition
officielle avec le petit caucus que vous
avez devant un si gros coquelus
gouvernemental écouter on a une équipe
renouvelée sur les 19 députés libéraux
on ne dix nouvelle députés et nouveaux
députés qui ont chacun leurs compétences
leur domaine de prédilection ils ont des
dossiers tous très important alors on le
voit notre rôle d'agir avec rigueur avec
sérieux avec respect aussi mais lorsque
nous verrons des injustices nous ne nous
priverons pas dans l'intérêt des
Québécois de les dénoncer et d'avancer
des solutions en quoi le discours du
pellicule au Salon bleu sera différent
sous marque Tanguay de ce que c'était
sous Dominique Anglade
je vais pas m'inscrire en contradiction
ou en changement majeur mes choses
certaines l'économie l'économie est un
dossier excessivement important pourquoi
tout part de là lorsque l'on parle de la
force de la nation francophone
québécoise c'est votre économie qui va
vous permettre d'atteindre votre
objectif de d'avoir l'épanouissement du
français lorsque vous voulez avoir des
services publics ça vous prend une
économie forte la lutte au changement
climatique on parle de transition
énergétique ben ça se fait via
l'économie l'économie comme moyen comme
outil d'atteindre nos objectifs
collectifs Marc Tanguay chef par intérim
du parti libéral du Québec merci d'avoir
été des nôtres merci à vous au plaisir